- I'm a very slow typer.
- That's part of why
we're parents. (laughter)
- There's a bunch of 'em.
- It's making me very emojinal.
- Is there a translator?
- There's such a thing
as too many options.
- This might take a lot
longer than I thought.
- Young people do this,
so that they could hide
their conversations from their parents.
- I don't know if I'm
spelling this correctly.
I know, I don't know. (laughter)
- This is so stupid, I don't know how
to communicate like this.
- Okay, I'm sendin' it.
- Okay, Sabrina sent me
something with just two emojis.
- A dog.
- Oh, doggone.
(laughter) There's an arrow.
- (laughter) We've picked the same one.
- Did you pick up the mail.
- Yeah.
- Okay, then look over with mine.
- Okay.
- Figure what mine is.
- Oh God, I'm in trouble.
- You're always coming home from running--
- All right, here's mine.
- So I'm like, it's like this,
hm, you're still running?
- Fist?
- No.
- Man, you wrote it out long.
- I can't see the emoji, it's so small.
- This?
- Do you know
how small these are, over here?
- Okay, now you are the opposite of me,
when you have one, two,
three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, 10, 11,
12, 13, 14, 15, 16 emojis.
- I'm an overachiever.
- Is it a letter?
- Uh huh.
- So mail?
- Uh huh, that was
supposed to be, not a car,
it was supposed to be a pickup.
- Oh, I got it, I got it, I got it.
Hey, you lady going to
the store in your minivan,
buy me all these foods.
- That's right. Are
you going to the store?
- There's a car.
- Well, I couldn't find a pickup.
- Well, how'm I supposed to.
- I put the eggplant in there
just to be sassy. (laughter)
- I only have four
characters, to your what, 12?
- Plant in emoji stands--
- For eggplant?
- for penis.
- Does it?
- Does it, really? (laughter)
Oh my gosh, kids today are so dirty!
- It was hard.
- I'm better at it than I
thought, that's my takeaway.
- I don't know, I just don't get it.
I mean, it makes sense on
Instagram, when you're like
tryin' to express an
emotion, with an emoji.
But, why would you like,
try to communicate?
- I don't think this is for me.
- It's not for me either.
- Maybe that's what emoji's really about,
is helping us get closer
to emotional communication,
through brain implants.